this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 70 sitting here with Echo Charlie
Echo Charles sure EC
sure all the above
and ejacqueline so on The Last
underground we talked about choking not
the Jiu Jitsu choking but the
performance choking
and I mentioned something called the
individual zones of optional optimal
functioning
which is that
level
of
attentiveness and pressure that actually
makes you perform better I talked about
surfing and how surfing without a leash
I could feel that I'm more focused I can
feel it's a more enjoyable
Rush more enjoyable feeling yeah a more
focused feeling
because if you mess up your board's gone
it's probably gonna get smashed by the
rocks
you have to swim far at a minimum you
gotta swim
which is a gut check so everything is
more focused so
that that level of stress is good so
there's a closely related psychological
theory or psychological Law related to
this it's called the yerks Dodson law
maybe it's the yerxes but the yerks
Dotson law named after a couple
psychologists Robert yerks and John
Dodson
and
it it says something very similar
basically that you have an area of
optimal stress that results in Optimal
Performance right so with too little
stress
your performance will be subpar due to
lack of attention due to lack of
interest to lack of focus this is when
you know when a parent's like oh yeah my
kid's really smart he's getting an F in
school or whatever yeah
and it's because they're bored that's
what this is right not enough stress so
not enough interest not enough attention
not enough Focus because there's not
enough stress
the other end of the spectrum we got too
much stress and now we have subpar
performance
because there's anxiety there's over
stimulation there's chemicals getting
released into the body there's a bunch
of things that are going on that if you
get too much stress you're going to have
a subpar performance and this this
original experiment
the way they conducted it the original
experiment was with mice and the mice
were uh
allowed to enter one of two boxes two
boxes
and the mice would enter into one of
these boxes one was black one was white
if they went into the black box there
was no shock
if they went in a white box they were
getting electrocuted like not
electrocuted but they were getting a
little yeah I guess the little electric
they were getting a shock and I'm sorry
everybody this is a experiment for like
1900 or 1905 or 1906.
so I apologize that the
mice were harmed
in this situation
with a really weak shock in the white
box
it took them a long time to figure out
the deal
with a really strong shock it took him a
long time to figure out the deal
with a medium shock
they figured out the deal
quickest so like not enough stress like
I don't really care when this box didn't
really phase me um
with too much shock they walk
what the hell just happened oh my God
what's going on too much
but when they gave him a shock that they
discomfort they didn't like but it
didn't freak them out that's where they
learned
the quickest that's where they for lack
of a better word performed
optimally now
this is where this gets complicated a
little bit it gets more complicated when
the task
gets more complicated because this is
what they figured out eventually for
humans
you for if it's a simple task
you can maintain good performance even
with high stress
if it's a complex task
that's where Things Fall Apart under
stress I mean this is common sense right
it's common sense
and you know there's there's a old
school version of self-defense
from like World War II
and their whole theory was based on
gross motor movements meaning I'm just
gonna like
big giant sweeping punches and big giant
sweeping stabs big giant gross motor
movements so I'm not gonna try and grab
like your fingers and manipulate because
it's too I prefer fighting to death in
combat I've got all this stress I'm not
gonna be able to perform these micro
movements these complex detailed
movements I'm gonna just get you with
the big giant you know clothesline to
the neck
so that kind of reminds me of that
that's actually a good theory
that they have there
um now all that being said
and again a lot of stuff is common sense
but it's worth thinking about
we can improve the performance under
stress of a complex task if we practice
if we rehearse if we repeat so
that's why you know shooting
a pistol shooting a rifle
you practice it I mean it's fairly
complex it's fairly complex if you're
someone that's never shot before and you
gotta line the front sight with the
backside you gotta you know hold good
position with your hands you got to do a
good there's a lot of stuff going on
there's a lot of individual movements
that are happening and yet once you get
good at pistol it's not even a thought
it's something you do it becomes very
very simple
so that's what
that's what we want to
that's what we want to do
now there's a lot just just FYI if
anyone wants to freak out
and and tell me that you know this this
psychological theory has been
disproven and the experiment and the
scientific protocols and the methods of
accuracy there's there's a lot of
there's some people that criticize it
and they morphed this law over time
but this much we know
and this much is important not all
stress is bad
right not all stress is bad
some stress is good no stress at all is
bad it doesn't stimulate
and this is something to think about
from a leadership position if you're if
you're not putting any challenges in
front of your team they're not going to
get in the game
and when you're a leader and you put too
much stress on your team they're gonna
be overwhelmed so you gotta find that
optimal level of stress and then we've
got a team and you want them to get good
at
doing something under stress you gotta
rehearse it they gotta practice it and
that includes leadership
again the primary goal of the training
that I used to run for the SEAL Teams
was to actually overwhelm
the leaders
massive stress
so that they could become accustomed to
it so they could come up with little
protocols on how to prioritize and
execute
so there you go
don't think of stress as something you
need to fight against think of it as
something you need to work with to find
the optimal level of stress with
yourself with your team so that everyone
can perform better
there you go
they say that uh you know it was
something about the current state of
children being spoiled or something like
this I don't know something like that it
was in an application of that they're
saying
um
when kids are spoiled it's it's not I
forget what it's not but all essentially
in it's on its base level it's
a low uh stress tolerance
or sorry a low distress tolerance so
like if you're used to getting what you
want at every turn
and then the moment you don't get what
you want that causes distress and they
have low tolerance because they don't
have any practice in being distressed
throughout life so they react
irrationally
that's what it is yeah a little
distressed
exercise is so good man because that's
something like you kind of learn the
idea of discomfort and pain in exercise
like if you go hard or even playing
sports and all this other stuff I kind
of you kind of has an adult you kind of
reflect on those things and be like you
realize the value of that totally
valuable
distressed
yep
all right let's go some q a q a first
question Jocko if I if I have
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground